El término teletransportación cuántica puede sonar como algo de ciencia ficción, pero como hablaremos en el episodio de hoy
de Kiskit en el Aula, es una técnica muy real y muy útil para la comunicación cuántica y
las redes. Bienvenido a Qiskit en el Aula. En esta serie, usaremos Qiskit para explorar algunos conceptos fundamentales
que se tratan habitualmente en cursos relacionados con la computación cuántica. Cada video está acompañado de un módulo interactivo
vinculado en la descripción a continuación, así que asegúrate de revisarlo. La teletransportación es una especie de tropo de la ciencia ficción y la fantasía
en este momento. Una persona u objeto desaparece de un lugar y aparece instantáneamente en otro lugar.
Por más genial que sería esto, desafortunadamente, este tipo de teletransportación al menos es imposible. Violaría el límite cósmico
de velocidad. Nada puede viajar más rápido que la luz. Pero la teletransportación cuántica es
posible. En la teletransportación cuántica, la información en lugar de la materia puede transmitirse entre dos
lugares distantes. Todo lo que necesitas es un par de partículas entrelazadas, una en cada sitio, y una forma de comunicar información clásica
entre los dos sitios. Este protocolo fue desarrollado en 1993 por un equipo
de científicos cuánticos, incluyendo a Charles Bennett de IBM. Lo llamaron teletransportación cuántica porque, similar a la
versión de ciencia ficción, la información cuántica desaparecía de un lugar y aparecía en otro lugar distante
sin nunca viajar a través del espacio intermedio. Puede parecer magia, pero como veremos, no hay nada
misterioso ni mágico al respecto. Está habilitado por el fenómeno del entrelazamiento cuántico junto con la comunicación
clásica. Hoy vamos a repasar el protocolo de teletransportación cuántica y cómo funciona. Y luego lo pondremos en
acción en una computadora cuántica real para teletransportar el estado de un qubit de un lado de un procesador cuántico de IBM al
otro. Así que así es como funciona la teletransportación cuántica. Supongamos que tenemos dos personas, Alice y Bob, que están separadas
por una gran distancia. Digamos que Alice tiene un qubit. Lo llamaremos qubit Q solo por conveniencia. Y está en algún
estado cuántico desconocido sq donde alpha 0 y alpha 1 son números
complejos. Alice quiere enviarle su estado a Bob, pero no tiene forma de enviar el qubit en sí. Puede ser que
él esté demasiado lejos, o quizás ella ni siquiera sabe exactamente dónde está Bob, así que no sabe a dónde enviarlo. Por suerte,
los amigos ya comparten un par de qubits entrelazados A y B, donde Alice tiene el qubit A y Bob tiene el qubit B. Y
estos qubits están entrelazados. Por entrelazados, quiero decir que aunque los dos qubits estén separados por una gran
distancia, sus estados están correlacionados de una manera que la física clásica no puede explicar. Este par entrelazado es
algo llamado un Ebit, que podemos usar como recurso en la computación y comunicación cuántica.
En este caso, Alice puede usar el EBIT como recurso para transmitir su información cuántica a Bob. Para ver cómo, vamos a
empezar escribiendo el estado conjunto de los tres qubits, donde he ordenado los qubits de forma algo arbitraria
en este punto, pero este orden será conveniente cuando ejecutemos nuestro experimento en Kiskit. En Qiskit, la forma estándar de
ordenar los qubits es de derecha a izquierda. Entonces, el estado del qubit cero aparecerá a la derecha.
Expandamos el estado un poco y reescribámoslo así. Entonces el primer paso en nuestro protocolo de teletransportación es
que Alice entrelace su qubit de datos con su mitad del qubit EBIT usando un gate C knot. Un gate C knot o KN controlado
cambiará el estado de un qubit, el qubit objetivo, dependiendo del estado de otro qubit, el qubit de control.
Si el qubit de control está en el estado cero, entonces no le pasa nada al objetivo. Y si el qubit de control está en
el estado uno, entonces el qubit objetivo se invierte. Entonces en este caso, el qubit de datos Q de Alice será el qubit de control y
su qubit Ebit A será el qubit objetivo. Así que los primeros dos términos no cambiaron nada con el C knot, pero los
últimos dos términos sí, porque el qubit de control Q estaba en el estado uno. Entonces Alice
aplicaría un gate Hadamard a su qubit de datos Q que lleva el estado 0 al estado 1/2 0 + 1 y el estado 1 a
1 sobre 2 0 -1. Voy a omitir algo de álgebra simple aquí que puedes intentar completar por tu cuenta si quieres.
Pero después de reorganizar algunos términos obtendrás un estado que se ve así. Así que ahora el estado entrelazado de tres qubits de Alice y Bob
parece un desastre completo. Pero mira lo que pasa si Alice mide ambos qubits. El estado de tres
qubits colapsará parcialmente a uno de estos cuatro
términos. Y en cada caso, Bob quedará con un estado de superposición con amplitudes relacionadas con el
estado desconocido inicial de Alice. Recuerda que las amplitudes son alpha 0 y alpha 1. Entonces,
por ejemplo, si Alice mide ambos qubits como cero, entonces el estado de Bob colapsará a este término, el estado
desconocido original que Alice quería teletransportar. Pero si Alice mide cero en el qubit A y uno en el qubit Q, entonces el estado de Bob
será este. Este estado puede transformarse en el estado original del qubit Q si Bob
aplica un gate Z, que invertirá este signo aquí. Pero Bob no sabrá hacer esto
hasta que sepa lo que Alice ha medido. Así que el siguiente paso en el protocolo es que Alice llame a Bob y le diga cuáles
fueron sus dos mediciones. Después de saber eso, sabrá qué operaciones realizar en su qubit para que coincida con
el estado original de Alice. Aquí hay una tabla de las cuatro mediciones posibles y las cuatro operaciones posibles que Bob
necesitará realizar en su qubit según esas mediciones. Bob podría necesitar realizar un gate Z, un gate X, o ambos para
transformar su qubit para que coincida con el qubit original de Alice. Este último paso, donde Alice llama a Bob, por cierto, es por qué
la teletransportación cuántica no viola la causalidad. Aunque el estado de Bob colapsó instantáneamente cuando Alice midió
sus qubits, Bob no podía obtener ninguna información de ese estado hasta que Alice le dijo a Bob lo que midió. Y
esa llamada estaba limitada por la velocidad de la luz. Acabamos de pasar por muchas matemáticas detalladas, así que el hecho increíble
de que acabamos de teletransportar información cuántica puede haberse perdido. Pero es realmente bastante asombroso. Al usar
el entrelazamiento como recurso, Alice pudo hacer una medición para destruir la información cuántica almacenada con ella y hacer que apareciera
en otro lugar distante con Bob. Esta distancia podría ser de cientos, incluso miles de kilómetros. Aún más
sorprendente, este protocolo ni siquiera requiere que Alice sepa exactamente dónde está Bob. Siempre que compartan un Ebit
y puedan comunicarse clásicamente entre sí, la teletransportación cuántica funcionará. Ahora, veamos cómo funciona esto
con Qiskit y en realidad teletransportar un estado cuántico en una computadora cuántica.
Empezaremos con tres qubits, uno cada uno para el qubit de datos Q y los qubits A y B que conformarán el E bit. Nosotros
comenzamos creando el E bit. Aplicamos un Hadamard en el qubit A seguido de un gate C knot
entre A y B para crear el estado entrelazado que buscamos.
Luego preparamos el qubit Q de Alice en un estado cuántico aleatorio aplicando una unitaria aleatoria mostrada por esta caja etiquetada
U. Luego viene la teletransportación. Primero el gate C knot entre los qubits Q y A. Luego el Hadamard en el
qubit Q. Luego las mediciones colapsan parcialmente el estado de modo que solo el qubit B de Bob está en una superposición.
Este es el punto en el que Alice llamaría a Bob y le diría lo que midió. Entonces Bob aplicaría algunos
gates dependiendo de esas mediciones. Estas cajas con contorno rojo significan gates condicionales. La primera significa
que Bob aplica un gate X a su qubit si el qubit A se mide como uno. Y
la segunda significa que también aplicará un gate Z si el qubit Q se mide como uno.
Así que ahora Bob debería tener un qubit en el mismo estado en que estaba el qubit de Alice en este punto aquí, después del gate unitario.
Si todo salió según lo planeado, entonces hemos teletransportado el estado cuántico. Pero ¿cómo verificamos eso? Podemos ejecutar el
mismo circuit pero hacer un pequeño cambio.
Aquí hemos añadido otra unitaria al final del circuit aplicada al qubit de Bob. Esta unitaria es la inversa de
la que aplicamos al principio al qubit de Alice. El razonamiento aquí es que si este primer gate creó el
estado cuántico que ahora está teletransportado al qubit de Bob, entonces este debería deshacerlo, llevando el qubit de Bob de vuelta al estado
cero. Pero por supuesto, esto deshace todo nuestro arduo trabajo de teletransportar el estado en primer lugar. Así que no querríamos
hacer esto si realmente quisiéramos hacer algo con el estado teletransportado y si estuviera verdaderamente en un estado cuántico desconocido,
no podríamos aplicar una unitaria para deshacerlo. De todos modos, esto es puramente para propósitos de diagnóstico para asegurarnos
de que la teletransportación fue exitosa. Si medimos el qubit de Bob en el estado cero, entonces podemos estar razonablemente
seguros de que la teletransportación funcionó. Una vez que estemos seguros de que nuestro protocolo funciona como se esperaba, podríamos eliminar esta
unitaria final y en realidad hacer algo con el estado teletransportado. Pero por ahora, simplemente asegurémonos de que funciona. Vamos a
ejecutar el circuit en una computadora cuántica. Podemos usar el muestreador primitivo de Qiskit para ejecutar este circuit
muchas veces y recopilar estadísticas sobre los resultados de las mediciones. Si teletransportamos perfectamente el estado de Alice a Bob en cada
ocasión, entonces Bob mediría su qubit como cero cada vez, pero con el ruido ambiental e imperfecciones en
los gates, podemos esperar ver algunas ejecuciones donde el qubit de Bob termine siendo uno. Pero siempre que la mayoría de las
veces el qubit de Bob se mida como cero, podemos considerarlo un éxito. Aquí tenemos un histograma de los resultados de las mediciones de
los tres qubits. La medición de Bob se muestra en la primera ranura de cada cadena de tres bits. Como se esperaba, los cuatro
resultados que corresponden a que su bit sea cero son mucho más probables que los otros cuatro. Entonces, hemos
teletransportado exitosamente un estado cuántico. Pero mira qué tan lejos teletransportamos. Este es un mapa de todos los
qubits en el procesador cuántico que usamos. Y en el experimento, usamos solo estos tres qubits.
El qubit de Alice estaba aquí y el qubit de Bob estaba aquí. Así que estaban casi uno al lado del otro. Podríamos haber
logrado lo mismo simplemente aplicando un par de gates swap, que como sugiere el nombre, simplemente intercambia los estados cuánticos
de dos qubits vecinos. La teletransportación cuántica es útil para transportar información cuántica a largas distancias, y
los estados cuánticos han sido teletransportados cientos de kilómetros antes. Para nuestros experimentos aquí, estamos limitados por el
tamaño del chip, pero podríamos hacer la teletransportación un poco más impresionante teletransportando un estado entre dos
qubits distantes en nuestra computadora cuántica. Así que vamos a intentarlo. Aquí está nuestro nuevo diagrama del circuit. Se ve un poco más
complicado, pero nada ha cambiado fundamentalmente excepto que ahora Alice y Bob crean su EBIT compartido,
luego se separan. Esta serie de líneas y X representan gates swap que mueven
los estados de Alice y Bob de un qubit a otro. Alice se mueve al qubit 1 y
Bob se mueve al qubit 12. Luego Alice crea su estado aleatorio en el qubit 0 con
esta unitaria. Ten en cuenta que ella está creando el estado después de que ella y Bob ya se han
separado. Así que Bob ya está lejos de ella.
Luego el protocolo de teletransportación continúa como antes y Bob termina con el estado original de Alice después de sus
operaciones condicionales. Aplicamos el gate unitario inverso y luego verificamos que el qubit de Bob esté
en el estado cero. Y nuevamente vemos que la mayoría de las veces el qubit de Bob se encontró en el estado
cero. Así que la teletransportación fue exitosa.
La tasa de éxito no es tan alta como cuando Alice y Bob estaban uno al lado del otro, sin embargo. Todos esos gates swap
pueden ser costosos y causar que el EBIT se degrade un poco. La teletransportación cuántica puede parecer magia, pero como hemos
visto, todo lo que se necesita es entrelazamiento, un canal de comunicación clásico, y algo de ingenio. La propuesta original de 1993
que hemos cubierto en este video formó la base para otros protocolos como la teletransportación de gate cuántico
y es un ingrediente esencial para la computación y las comunicaciones cuánticas.
En el frente experimental, los científicos han seguido empujando los límites de la teletransportación cuántica, logrando incluso teletransportar
el estado cuántico de un fotón entre un laboratorio en la Tierra y un satélite a 1.400 km
por encima de él. Y teletransportar estados cuánticos a través de un cable de internet clásico ruidoso. Si quieres teletransportar tu propio
estado cuántico, dirígete al módulo de teletransportación cuántica vinculado en la descripción a continuación. Gracias por ver
y nos vemos la próxima vez.